- All right, it's a whole Barbie hour.
So, let's finish up
with something that
celebrates the iconic toy.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
He says playing with
dolls is just for kiddos.
A Maryland woman
recently discovered her
passion for Barbies.
And she's blowing up social media
with videos of what she
calls Mini Meynelle.
In the clips, you can see Mini
Meynelle doing everyday tasks
like figuring out what to wear
from her exclusive and
extensive mini-closet
or winding down after a long day.
Her videos have racked
up millions of views.
We have her on the line
right now to tell us more.
Let's say hi to Meynelle,
watching on NBC Washington.
(audience cheering)
Hi, Meynelle.
So, you say dolls are kind
of new in your life, right?
- Yeah, so growing up,
I never really saw dolls
that really looked like me
or really represented me for who I was.
So, it wasn't until recently
where I saw dolls on the
shelves diversify a little more.
And that's when I started collecting.
I started building more sets for them.
And I started to collect more things.
The pandemic also aided in that,
because it reignited my love for crafting.
And that, coupled with my
newfound love for dolls,
helped me form what my TikTok is today.
I would collect miniature
items for my mini me,
like food and furniture.
And yeah, I wanted her to
really reflect who I was.
- I love crafting as well.
So, you've developed
serious skills though,
in the videos and in crafting.
So, what have you learned
and what's next for you?
- Well, most of what I have
learned, it's a bit self-taught.
For example, I started doing
stop-motion in my videos.
I would take my mini me,
I'd move her, take another picture,
move her, snap another picture,
and it'd be that repetitive process
until I made a cute
little movie or a video.
I also started making
doll houses and doll rooms
for my mini me.
Something new that I
would love to get into
for my doll and I is traveling more.
I definitely wanna travel with her more.
I wanna take pictures with her out more.
I've been to DC and I've
been to New York with her.
But I would really love
to take her to the beach.
- Oh, my gosh, I love this.
And by the way, my kids are obsessed
with watching the stop-motion stuff,
like they would love this.
And also, my kids love dolls.
So, thanks so much, Meynelle.
I'm liking your post right now.
I hope you get to the beach.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction, the go to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like yourself, ma'am.
So, to get you to the
beach and to help you out,
they're gonna give you $1,000.
- Thank you.
- It was lovely to meet you, Meynelle.
Thank you so much to all
of our guests this hour.
Margot Robbie, Hilary Clinton,
America Ferrera, and Lawrence Aaron.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.